this is the revolutionary guard's
message to israel
war games in iran including firing
ballistic and cruise missiles
one of the targets resembles israel's
demona nuclear reactor
the head of iran's armed forces
staff major general mohammad bahri says
16 ballistic missiles of varying classes
were fired simultaneously
tehran has one of the biggest missile
programs in the middle east
regarding such weapons as an important
deterrent and retaliatory force against
the united states and other adversaries
in the event of war
just days after those drills world
powers are back in vienna trying to
salvage what is left of the 2015 nuclear
deal
the joint comprehensive plan of action
has been unraveling since the u.s
withdrew from it in 2018 and imposed the
series of new sanctions on iran
and that prompted iranian officials to
reduce their compliance with the deal
which means their nuclear program has
progressed
robert kelly is a former director of the
international atomic energy agency and a
nuclear engineer
he says iran's been backed into a corner
each time there's a sabotage event that
blows up some of their facilities or the
us adds more sanctions
they've tended to push back and do
something provocative and i think
they've gone past the point of
reasonable provocations they're now um
they've gone too far
world powers have been insisting that
iran's ballistic missile program needs
to be part of that deal
a notion that's continuously dismissed
by iran as the eighth round of talks
continue here in the austrian capital
israel opposes these efforts and has
long threatened military action if
diplomacy fails and that is just one of
the many reasons time is of the essence
there is a sense of urgency in all
delegations
that this negotiation has to be
finished in a relatively reasonable
period of time again i would put limits
but we are talking about weeks not about
months
the head of iran's atomic energy
organization mohammed islami recently
told a russian media outlet that iran
does not intend to go beyond its current
enrichment levels of 60 percent a move
all western powers have warned would
cross a red line
iran says its nuclear program has always
been for civilian use a statement some
don't believe while it continues to
stock by highly enriched uranium
officials here say for tensions to ease
and for iran to limit its nuclear
program the talks here must succeed and
failure will have far reaching
consequences
dorsal jabari al jazeera vienna